First, let's make sure
we have ggplot2 loaded.
So library(ggplot2).
Now let's load our data frame,
which is in households.csv.
So read.csv(households.csv).
If we look at the
structure of households,
we see that there is
a year column and then
six other columns for each of
the different household types.
So this is actually
a problem for us.
Given this structure
of a data frame,
what would we put
in the aesthetic
for our ggplot command?
It's not obvious,
to me at least,
and in fact, I don't think
it's really possible.
The reason is that
ggplot needs it
in the form of: year,
group, and fraction.
The solution is to
use the melt function
from the reshape package.
Melt will take a 2-dimensional
data frame like ours,
and convert it into exactly the
right form we need for ggplot2.
So first, let's load reshape2
-- library(reshape2).
Now, let's look at the first two
columns of our households data
frame -- households[,1:2].
So there's a Year and a
MarriedWChild for each year.
Now, let's look at the first few
rows of our melted households
data frame.
So head(melt(households,
id="Year")).
And there you have it.
So, basically,
what's happened is
that each value of
MarriedWChild has
turned into its own row
in the new data frame.
To make it more clear,
perhaps, let's look
at the first three
columns of households.
Now we have MarriedWOChild.
Now let's look at, instead
of just the first rows
of our melted data frame, let's
look at the first 10 rows.
So rows 1 to 10, all columns.
There we go.
So there you can see the
eight values of MarriedWChild,
and the first two values
of MarriedWOChild.
So there's that 30.3 up
there, gone down to 30.3 here,
29.9 gone to down here.
So every value in
our data frame now
corresponds to a new row
in our melted data frame,
which is exactly what
we need for ggplot.
So let's try plotting this
melted data frame -- ggplot,
melt, households, using the
Year column as an id column,
the key column.
Our aesthetic is going to be
now to use Year on the x-axis.
Our y-axis will be the value
column of our melted data
frame.
And the color of
the line will depend
on the group, which is called
variable in the melted data
frame.
So that's our aesthetic.
Our geometry is
going to be lines.
And I want to make the
lines a little bit thicker.
So let's say line size is 2.
And I also want to have
points for each year
in the data frame, so I'm
going to have lines and points.
So geom_point.
And I'm going to make the size
of these a little bit bigger
than normal too, size = 5.
And we should put
a y-axis label.
So ylab("Percentage
of Households").
And there you go.
Now, this is actually
quite interesting
when we compare it back to the
chart we had in the slides.
Now you can see just how
quickly MarriedWChild
is decreasing as
a relative share.
You can also more clearly
see that MarriedWOChild
is pretty much flat, and that
the differences being made up
by the other four
types of households
is steadily increasing
over the years.
So there you have
it, the same data,
plotted in two different ways.
Now, I'm not saying one of these
is better than the other one.
For example, if I want to
compare inside a given year,
say 1970, it's not the most
easy thing, at a glance,
to see just how much of
a total hundred percent
is taken up by each.
But if I want to see across
years, it's far superior.
And I can clearly see that the
last data point is pretty much
right next to the
second to last data
point, which is
something that was
hard to tell with the
other visualization.
So I hope this has made
you think a little bit more
about the different ways
you can plot the same data.
And hopefully improved
your ggplot2 skills
a little bit more.
Thanks for watching.